this is the moment police came for a
former hong kong legislator
all across the city more doors were
being knocked on more charges read out
the crackdown had begun more than a
thousand police officers moved to our
scores of pro-democracy activists
this was the biggest operation to date
under the national security law
imposed by beijing on hong kong last
year
many had feared the law's sweeping
powers and these were sweeping
arrests arrests that included the first
foreigner to be detained under the law
a u.s human rights lawyer continue to
work for democracy
and human rights in hong kong the charge
subverting state power
we are finding some people have been uh
seriously interfering and disrupting
and undermining the operation of the
hong kong government
the allegedly subversive plan was this
to win more than 35 seats a majority
in elections for the legislative council
hong kong's parliament
everyone arrested today was involved in
these primaries held last july
to choose pro-democracy candidates ahead
of the elections
some candidates have promised that if
they won a majority they would reject
bills proposed by the government
and veto its budget many would call that
the job of an opposition in an elected
chamber in beijing
the chinese state called it subversion
the rights and freedom hong kong people
enjoyed have not been affected in any
way
what was affected was that some external
forces and
individuals in hong kong colluded with
each other
in an attempt to undermine the stability
and security of china
the few pro-democracy politicians who
hadn't been arrested
it gathered really an affront
to the constitutionally protected
rights to vote of hong kong people
and this is totally unacceptable
the chinese communist party once
described the national security law as a
sword
hanging over hong kong today it looked
more like a hammer
tom cheshire sky news beijing